foreign
hey what's going on you guys Tom is
going off into the next person's video
oh [ __ ]
I'm in the video next to it this is his
little bald heads
okay okay what it's the same you're in
the same spot yeah I'm in the same spot
okay it looks look it looks like that I
know you're confused but see that's what
it looks like full see
so I got plenty of room over there okay
all right it's just you can't see it
because I have the chat window open
because I need to see this all right you
know what I mean
you got me all right yeah
okay so hey it's a haunting Mondays yeah
Jamie Rowling yeah you are
um yeah you reminded me I was like the
step dad that actually plays the stepdad
in this one oh we're gonna have lots of
jokes about that guy because he's a dick
holy crap what a [ __ ] knuckle that guy
was but um I don't know not cool I don't
know if that's what the real guy was
like or not but like the whole time I
was watching I was like man look at that
Bob Vila looking [ __ ] but now
that you mention it he actually does
look more like that dude from Home
Improvement actually maybe that's what
it actually it wasn't that dude was it I
don't think it was but I've seen Home
Improvement I I saw it like a long time
ago like a couple times but I know who
he's talking about and he even like wore
the same stuff like he wore the same
kind of like uh he always kind of had
those flannel shirts on and [ __ ] like
that so he looks like a lot like he
basically looks almost exactly like that
guy I think he was slightly less chubby
but that's about it
but yeah I think that I think that guy
was simultaneously the most entertaining
and the most like hateable part of this
episode because it's just like the whole
time I was like he's doing his job he's
supposed to be a dick yeah I was like
wow what a like what a [ __ ] that guy
was like I said I don't know what he was
like in real life he's just the uh the
Dick's stepfather
yeah the evil stepdad yeah now I will
note that I did find a little bit of
outside
material about this okay now we've got
some uh theories about this show
yeah
um
I have to say that it's like I hadn't
really remembered much about this one
and I think I remembered there was like
you know witchcraft involved obviously
because it was called Spellbound but
yeah this one seemed a little bit
um
it's out of character for uh slightly I
kind of feel like it was it doesn't fit
well documented documented paranormal
cases uh in terms of you know the
patterns in which things happen
um things that things that I would
consider to be kind of like a legit case
it doesn't really follow
uh what parapsychology you would you use
normally look for
um
it follows other patterns I'll let Jenny
get into that probably
um but it's it's it's not what it
appears to be I don't think and it
seemed like well you're saying I think
it's a hoax
yeah I mean it's well not a lot happened
in it the thing about it though is that
I found some stuff like on the you know
kind of not you know outside the scope
of the show like from the real people
and apparently like a few more things
happened that they didn't show on the
show but I still kind of think I don't
know like I said I have some theories
about this kind of [ __ ] for a case to be
paranormal paranormal things have to
happen
and
supposedly if a paranormal thing happens
I have seen paranormal stuff so is Jenny
it has to be witnesses to it it has to
be pretty recurrent in other words it
has to be something that happens several
times or many times and you know it's a
real phenomena that's happening and I
don't really see that in this but
you know
to me the religion's involved with this
yeah that's a nice way about it yeah
there's a certain phenomena involved in
churches
um where
sometimes to get street cred as a
preacher you can claim to be a Satanist
they used to be a Satanist yeah yeah
please be saying this and then you tell
Satan it's a very very common because
they love that Redemption Arc thing yeah
I mean and then there's Redemption arcs
in the story basically and uh there's
there's religious arcs inside the story
and um it's just um
it's too well it's just kind of churchy
you know yeah this one was a little bit
churchy it was church it's kind and not
to say that you know
if it involves a church it's bunk I'm
not saying that it's just that uh this
fits a pattern you know what I mean oh I
used to be a next con but I changed my
life and now I'm a preacher oh I used to
be a Satanist I changed it I changed it
my mom was a witch and now I'm a
preacher I just you know just that kind
of stuff you know
it's unlikely you know
I mean it's always you're always likely
that you kind of cook up a story yeah
because the thing about it is that I
guess there's like a lot of competition
I wouldn't know but it's like I guess
there's a lot of competition like would
be in ministers and stuff and they kind
of want to get like attention you want
people to come to your church and stuff
yeah and it's like it's kind of boring
to just say oh I was raised religious
and I decided to become a minister at
the end like that's a really boring
story you want to sex it up a little bit
you know what I mean oh I used to be a
heroin addict I used to be a heroin
addicted Satanist hooker you know what I
mean it's like
just anything so you can say that it's
like hey I was like the worst of the
worst and I was able to redeem is even
if it's probably not true or it's like
wildly exaggerated which I think it is
in a lot of cases yeah and this tended
not to work with our generation it
tended to work with people that were
older than us they kind of were they
were more kind of uh um they're more
likely to be into the church thing
and then to fall for
stories you know it's very rare that you
find a person that I ever find a person
that would believe a church story you
know
churches nowadays around here as far as
I know they're more like happy clappies
and I don't even they wouldn't get into
the [ __ ] demonic stuff
yeah I mean I haven't I haven't been to
him yeah I probably like uh catch on
fire if I walked in there
[Laughter]
was pray to pray the gay away there was
a lot of that they're still doing that
so they're still doing it yeah or you
know whatever
laughs
Zach says I now want uh want to write a
really upsetting dark comedy about the
hook or character James just came up
with right
Danny rolling also says the look on the
Sun's face when he saw the painting of
Satan in his room was priceless I mean
the whole uh yeah I want to get into
that because well the thing about it is
like that painting it's like that
technically wasn't really Satan it was
just kind of like the wicked kind of
like god and goddess figures you know
what I mean I didn't say it wasn't
really Satan yeah
I like how you know wiccanism now is
instantly Satanism yeah
which uh it's like we're judging the
Wake today because what we were watching
I was like oh it's another blame the
Goths episode didn't it yeah
there's a lot of those
I never really considered Wicca to be a
real folk religion anyway it's not very
old
I think it might have been re-codified
by groups of people yeah it draws on
older things but it was on older things
but it's not that old no and it tends to
be kind of hippie type yeah chicks and
proto-goth women that kind of were into
Stevie Nicks or something you know it's
kind of like that you know
um I didn't even know any goth girls
that were into Wicca well not any real
what goth girls they were into it um I
knew a very Runner CEO but it wasn't
really that much of a thing they didn't
take it seriously maybe they might draw
some from some motifs of that but I
don't think they believed it
yeah I think more it was just kind of
more like a fun thing to do I don't
really think anybody really believed
anything was gonna come out of it but it
seemed like pretty harmless you know
what I mean just having little goth girl
I knew who was basically an atheist yeah
and he didn't believe any kind of
Supernatural stuff right that's what I'm
saying I kind of feel like that's I
don't know but I did know a couple that
were like serious about it they ran a
shop and everything and they really did
believe all that stuff but they were
actually like really really nice they
weren't like weirder they weren't
hippies or nothing like that they were
kind of gothy but
probably like the same kind of and they
were they were girls they were same kind
of girls that'd be into like dragons and
wizards and yeah that kind of stuff go
to the Renaissance Festival
yeah it's yeah that's that's kind of
like what these two were like they're
more like that they weren't they weren't
threatening or anything no not at all
that's why I always kind of laugh at
like a lot of these haunting episodes
that ones that have the wiccans on them
like there's and then they practice
Wicca and I was like yeah oh my God and
there's people in Black robes
[Laughter]
[ __ ] satanic rights maybe there's
some people that's like very scary I'm
just like yeah okay whatever yeah so
it's like they probably like you said
they probably just go to the ren Fest
and yeah [ __ ] hanging out playing d
and d and [ __ ] yeah it's not really on
velvet handbags right it's not really
that scary trust me they're they're fine
they're burning herbs and smudges
they're not gonna hurt you bring the
sage
you know and then there's some crystals
on stuff
fake Native American guys pretending to
be Native Americans in a [ __ ] drum
circle with the sages right yeah what
tribe are you in oh I'm a no I'm gonna
know what you call it tribe oh yeah yeah
what you call it what you call it yeah
yeah they're part of the Lakota people
yeah that's right yeah yeah
they fake anything here in the United
States
yeah yeah
Zach says do you guys consider The
Exorcist to be a religious movie
um kinda it sort of is yeah I don't
actually responsible for a religious
revival it was yeah because people were
like oh [ __ ] it's all it's real yeah
Zach also says have you all ever seen
Summer of Sam yes I actually saw that in
the theater when it came out and I saw
it like on cable I actually remember it
being pretty good
yeah it's basically Spike Lee trying to
do a Scorsese movie about the Son of Sam
murders and it is bizarre yeah it was a
lot weirder than I remembered like I
think what I saw in the theater when it
came out I was like oh that's pretty
good but when I saw it again I was like
that was kind of a weird movie
but I liked it though I don't know
oracle says uh Tom and Jenny there's a
mini series adaptation of midwinter of
the spirit which features the Reverend
merrily Watkins a C of E Exorcist and
you might like it I think I've
recommended the books to Jenny before uh
yeah that might actually be interesting
uh midwinter of the spirit where what is
that on Netflix or something um I don't
know do I have to look it up okay
um let's see Oracle also says also I'm
perkier than usual today because I spoke
to my little sister yesterday and I'm
gonna be an aunt in a couple months oh
that's cool like congratulations I mean
not you know congratulations to you for
being an aunt I know you're not the one
that's right
uh Dana Rowling said yeah of course it's
a religious film it has to do with
Catholics I mean the that's the thing
it's
it's I think it's kind of like the
perfect religious movie because
it's a religious movie in this in the
sense that like the Catholics are the
good guys and demons are real and they
battle them and stuff like that but it's
like it's not it wouldn't like it's not
preachy and it wouldn't turn off
somebody that didn't believe any of that
stuff because it's just like a horror
movie it's like a horror movie there's a
lot of them it's like you know the
prophecy was like that Christopher
Walken I think yeah two of those maybe
three they're pretty fun yeah about
angels Fallen Angels
um
kind of like a vampire movie but they
were Fallen Angels doing weird [ __ ]
right
um there's a lot of them that were like
that Noah was great Darren aronofsky's
Noah fantastic that was like
something out of the Ridley Scott or you
know what I mean like yeah
it was a creepy movie I told you you
might like his newer movie mother as
well that's uh that's a ride
that's also kind of like a Biblical
allegory but it's weirder I don't know
if it's weirder it is kind of weird I
really liked it but a lot of people
really did it I had a lot of
religious and Christian movies the one
where the damn
dude dude was telling us telling his
kids these people were possessed by
demons they were bringing them in and
killing them
Frailty Frailty fantastic horror movie
yeah it was really good yeah because the
thing about it is that I'm not really
bothered by like a religious horror
movie yeah because the thing about it is
that
I mean they're like well I don't really
believe demon possession is real but I
was like well I don't believe vampires
and Bigfoot and [ __ ] is real either but
it's like I'll watch horror movies about
that I'm able to like it's called
imagination like I can suspend my
disbelief I just see it like the same
way as that yeah had that had that guy
that was in uh
aliens yeah the guy that played uh
Hudson Bill Paxton Bill Paxton I think
he directed it too yeah it was a good
movie
he's bringing he's bringing he's got
these two little sons and he's bringing
people in there all tied up and they're
like begging for mercy can't you see it
that's a demon you look and and the the
young son is telling the story can't see
it but his older brothers
yeah and eventually the the the the
older brother's like yeah I know I see
it now I see it and they were killing
people so they were women tied up and P
dudes and the mailman and just and it
was [ __ ] creepy and it turned out
they are demons who knew that the
mailman was the date yeah they were
demons [ __ ] male man
or at least you or maybe you go crazy
along with them and you start seeing
them as see there's a lot of different
interpretations different
interpretations you know what I mean
yeah see normally if a movie pulled that
kind of stuff because I have seen a
couple of other movies that did pull
that where it was just kind of like
they're like oh like the crazy religious
people are are right
um and normally that would piss me off
but for whatever reason like that movie
didn't piss me off you're scary it was
scary yeah
you know it's creepy because you're like
oh man those kids are [ __ ] going
through hell their dad's a serial killer
yeah you know
yeah I mean it's it's a pretty it's an
awesome movie I feel like it's still
people like I feel like they know about
it now but I still I feel like it's
still a little bit underrated yeah low
budget movie it's low budget yeah but it
was just well made it was yeah
uh holy Parish of demon said I thought
there was something at the end of
Frailty that tips the reality of the
story in favor of the supernatural yeah
that's true we haven't seen it in a
while but yeah I'm pretty sure that yeah
yeah been quite a while since I've
watched it yeah we've reviewed it but
it's been a couple of years I think
but uh yeah so we said all that to say
uh uh you know that we're gonna be
talking about haunting oh before we do
that I don't know is Louis here uh I
didn't see him okay well
I guess we'll we'll do this again like
on the main show because Louie might be
here for that but we just got a package
from Louisville we will announce it when
he's here huh yeah we will announce it
when Louie's here yeah I mean I would
definitely do it now too okay but you
know just because I want to show other
people too but I just want to say like
we'll announce it when he's here as well
and he might be watching it later I'm
not really sure so we just got a package
from Louie like about like an hour ago
and he sent us
the oh he sent us Reservoir Dogs
nice which I haven't seen in like
forever yeah also Pulp Fiction yeah so
we'll probably be doing one of these
that's 4K hopefully it has a Blu-ray
also because I can't play 4K yeah it
yeah it says 4K Ultra Plus okay Blu-ray
okay digital code yeah good you're fine
you're fine 4K TV and he said let's say
50 gift card thank you very much thank
you very very much Louie yeah you were
part of Christmas present yeah we'll get
right on those we'll review
yeah I've seen them both but I haven't
seen them in a long time I've seen them
both too I've only seen Reservoir Dogs
probably once or twice I've seen Pulp
Fiction a bunch of times like I think I
saw that in the theater they're both
good ones yeah out of his catalog those
are two of the best ones we should
actually probably watch one tonight and
talk about it on the matinee tomorrow so
that would be good
uh Zach said last night I watched a
really bad mummy rip-off type movie by
the guy who did Battlefield Earth and it
stank just as bad what was it called was
it just called The Mummy
or was it now are we talking about like
the original mummy like the Boris
Karloff one or are we talking about like
the Tom Cruise one look man I don't give
a [ __ ] what you all say I will defend
plant I will defend Battlefield Earth
well I know you will I will defend
battlefielders you're going to be out
there alone defending it though
it's it's a fun experience to watch you
and John Travolta and David yeah
standing there in a field all by
yourself
I think it's a I think Battlefield Earth
is a fun experience when you know where
it came from
uh L Ron Hubbard stuff what the search
of Church of Scientology is like what
they're trying to say
and just the stories behind that movie
that that movie was it's fun to watch
when you know what it is they're trying
to say because it's ludicrous you know
yeah it's ludicrous well their whole
[ __ ] is when you actually know what it
is
I mean you know they're trying to say
that a dude that looks a lot like David
miscav is just saving the human race
from Evil aliens that believe in all
this crazy [ __ ] corporate things and
they're just here to [ __ ] abuse
everybody and take their money and you
can wait a minute hold on that's
confession by projection yeah it was
like um that's what you got yeah that's
what you got
are you really not that self-aware are
you trying to fake us out or what yeah
the cyclos the cyclo the alien cyclos is
what they're called everything they're
about is exactly what Scientology
actually does not what it says but what
it does yeah
so they can't be that clueless well I
don't know how they can I guess they can
yeah I can't say that about people but
then I'm like oh yeah I guess people can
be the nucleus well a lot of
organizations do that I know they are
exactly the opposite of what they say
they are and they and the ones up up top
no
you know they know they know that
they're not like that they are the
opposite of what they say they are
or they've talked or they've just talked
themselves into believing their own
[ __ ]
but I I think it's I think David
miscavige knows it's [ __ ] Tammy says
wow can't wait for Reservoir Dogs yeah
like I said probably let's do Reservoir
Dogs first because I haven't seen that
one in a longer time yep I remember I
remember that one being my favorite of
of uh Tarantino
I think it might be mine too but like I
said I haven't seen it in a long time so
I can't remember and Pulp Fiction was
good yeah oh that was like my second
favorite I'm not a huge Tarantino fan
but but his crime stuff is in it those
are to his best I think those are his
best ones I mean and I will say too that
I really really liked Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood
uh yeah that's right that one was really
good we saw that and uh that was really
really good and um the one that he wrote
but didn't direct it was called True
Romance yeah that was good that was
really good oh [ __ ] we haven't reviewed
that one yet have we we should probably
do that one too that was really his
first movie because I like that movie a
lot yeah had Christian Slater and
Patricia Arquette
and Gary Oldman yeah that's right it was
a crime Thriller real good and and
he wrote the screenplay but he didn't
direct it it's really good though right
really good it's better than a lot of
his movies that he directs
but Zach's talking about that shitty
mommy movie uh he said I think it was
called gods of the Sun or something it
was weird and bad now I kind of want to
see it
really Parish of Doom says
authoritarians are big on psychological
projection uh cognitive dissonance yeah
yeah I've noticed yep
um and then uh brennaire says I think
Pulp Fiction is my favorite and then
hateful eight yeah I hateful eight is
good too I like it yeah I like that one
that wasn't like that one as well yeah
sometimes sometimes Tarantino is on and
sometimes he's off
just depends we went to middle school
together
Dominguez Elementary
well that's elementary school elementary
school yeah well that's Middle School no
it's not isn't it no okay middle school
that's right it's Elementary School is
six to eight I think right yeah isn't
that middle school that's right yeah it
was Dominguez Elementary in Carson
California he was a little bit older
than me though I remember him but he was
out of there
uh about a year or two two years maybe
before I was but I remember him
and uh my friends Jimmy and Mike used to
see him all the time working at the
video rental store
up there on [ __ ] not on Alameda but I
forgot what street that was I can I
could picture but I remember the name of
that street
build their nearest supermarket on the
corner
that's where he uh studied film he
studied film with the video rental place
near near our school
and behind that school is where Jesse
James Chopper shop was
that um
it was built in a dam
industrial park that didn't exist when I
lived there it was just Strawberry
Fields behind the railroad tracks
and we're [ __ ] was West Coast
Choppers I think is what it was called
yeah
brennaire said he wrote Natural Born
Killers as well oh yeah I forgot about
that yeah Natural Born Killers are yeah
that was the one with uh Woody Harrelson
yeah yeah that's right Juliette Lewis
that's right that's a good movie yeah
that was also a really good movie so
maybe that's the secret like he should
write things and not direct them
although I like some of the ones your ex
is good yeah yeah once upon a time when
Hollywood was [ __ ] great yeah I loved
that man I forgot I have it I forgot
that I forgot that he did that one
and then I think I bought it for you for
Christmas yeah I think overall that's
his best movie
yeah I mean yeah that's his best one
that's an awesome movie I mean it's
great because it's like a hangout movie
but it's also like really I don't know
it's just like really really awesome
anybody can watch that movie and enjoy
it because you just kind of get into it
and it ends [ __ ] crazy
it ends the way you want it to end
instead of the way it really ended in
real life yeah yeah yeah a lot of space
movies are like that yeah they're like
they're like wish fulfillment yeah
but that's okay that's what movies are
for you know what I mean it's like it's
kind of boring if you want to show like
what really happened just make a
documentary you know
uh Danny rolling said wasn't Natural
Born Killers Loosely based on spree
killer Charles Stark weather yeah it was
Loosely based on that we did a show
about Charles Stark weather did we not
uh I don't think so
I don't think we did Stark weather I
thought we did but I have to go check
yeah we've done like so many shows you
know what's interesting I was gonna say
like just you know before we get back
into the actual topic but um I get uh
the end of year YouTube thing that
always shows you like the videos that
were the most watched like all year long
and do you know one of the ones I can't
remember what the first most popular one
was but you know what the second most
popular one was was the Herb Baumeister
the Fox Hollow Farm Show ours yeah weird
Okay that was like the second most
popular of our videos this year that's
what I was watching I was like why that
one I can't remember it's in my email
but it's like I can't write it was
another one that I was like huh it was
like a weird one that I wouldn't have
that I wouldn't have thought it might
have been a movie review now that I'm
thinking about it good maybe not
hmm I can't remember what it was but I
just I I thought that was really really
weird that it wasn't it wasn't like new
ones it was always like old ones that
were like the most popular but I don't
know that's like really strange I was
like that's probably good
that's good info to have though because
that's like your most popular one so you
can kind of do more stuff along those
lines I guess
all right so
um Brenner says Quentin Tarantino has a
podcast called the video archives
podcast and he's been talking about
gialos mostly really interesting stuff
hearing his opinions on 70s Italian
films I might actually have to go listen
to that because I'm really really into
Glo movies
um you know and I didn't know that he
had a podcast where he was just talking
about that like that sounds pretty
awesome actually all right so are we
ready to get into
a haunting yes Spellbound
all right so this episode is from season
four and it's episode seven it came out
in 2007.
so this is one of those ones that like
spans a really long period of time right
so it starts out in 1965.
in Geneva Ohio Danny Rowling also
pointed out that there was another
episode called the Unleashed that was
also about a Wiccan oh yeah and he said
oh they shot it in the same two houses
and I was like I knew those [ __ ]
houses in this show looked familiar
because I said that to you last night I
was like I know they put that house the
one that they live in at first I was
like I know they put that in another
episode but I couldn't remember which
one it was because I imagine they
probably just like they reuse some of
the same actors the reused actors that
sounds gross but um I'm sure they use
like some of the same houses as well but
so yeah so this is taking place in
Geneva Ohio so we have a woman named
Sandra Waldron and that is her real name
and her son Jean which I guess that's
just what they call him like that's not
his actual like I found out what his
real name was like a gene is his middle
name like but I'll get into that like
later on because he actually like wrote
some books later
so they've just moved into their new
house
along with Sandra's husband and Gene's
stepfather whose name is Steven I guess
that's his real name
um and like I said he's this kind of
douchey [ __ ] who looks kind of
like Bob Vila or
um Al from [ __ ] Home Improvement
right complete with like the Plaid
[ __ ] flannel shirts and he works at
like an engineering company
so Gene who was on the show like he said
that Stephen was pretty much the only
dad he'd ever known because he'd been
like his stepdad since he was like two
or three years old and I guess he didn't
remember his dad like prior to that and
um you know so we'll get more into
Stephen later because Stephen
oh Stephen so anyway uh so one day like
in this new house that they have moved
to
Sandra notices there's like a stone
marker it's kind of like a grave but
it's like not really a grave I guess
even though it's kind of like a
commemorative they call it a Cornerstone
I guess which I don't think that's
really accurate because Cornerstone
would be like hey there was this
building here but it was kind of like
marking
where somebody had died like the school
master from a school that apparently
used to be on the property
um this is apparently where the school
Master died like I don't they don't know
then they never said like how the person
died but they just dropped dead in that
very spot and they're like oh quick like
put a [ __ ] cement slab there like to
commemorate this occasion I don't know
it's really weird so they kind of put it
there the stone says the school was
established in 1880 but
um I don't think it said like when the
guy died although like I said I found it
like somewhere else later on so we'll
talk about that later
now
um like I said they didn't say on the
show like who this dead person was or
when they died but I did find out
something about that like later
so Stephen comes home in his truck from
work
and this is one of many times where I
was just like oh my God somebody needs
to like punch this [ __ ] in the face so
Sondra is like oh can you take Gene
inside and like get him like you know to
wash his hands or clean him up for
dinner or whatever because I'm gonna go
make dinner and then Steven's like
I just got home from work and all I want
to do is like go in and change my
clothes and relax and water I'm like oh
my God here we go so you know what I
mean and she's basically saying hey I
told you that you know parenting is a 24
7 job and you know you need to help out
and he's just like fine okay so I was
just like Jesus Christ all right
so uh Sandra mentions at this point
because the real Sandra is on the show
as well and she said she always got the
feeling that Steven never accepted Jean
as his own son even though he'd
apparently been a stepdad since he was
like two or three years old so this has
been a while because I think the kid was
like he looked like what about eight he
looked like about eight or something
like that on the show
um and Sandra said that Steven always
seemed kind of like resentful like he
didn't really want anything to do with
the kid
sonder also said that she personally had
always been really interested in the
occult ever since she was a little kid
so she mentions this stone that she
found in the front yard and Stephen
actually being normal for a second says
oh yeah our neighbor Denise said
something about you know there yeah
there used to be a school on the
property so Sandra gets really excited
and she's like oh does Denise know how
this guy died but then Steven snaps back
into douche mode then then Barry that's
it he really only has honestly he really
only has that mode
douche mode pretty much it's it's just
like douche mode and slightly less
douche mode it's kind of like just stuck
over there so so he very condescendingly
tells Sandra don't start any of that
Hocus Pocus garbage again that's what he
said
um you've been spending too much time
reading those weird books of yours and I
was like okay and maybe you should spend
more time taking care of the house yeah
instead of free cleaning the house
thought I said cleaning the house no
well he said taking care of the house or
like looking after the house or
something like that right and I was like
yeah
yeah
clean this house up stop reading him
books and that's the thing it's like the
house didn't look I mean obviously this
is a reenactment so it's like I don't
know maybe the house was a [ __ ] I
don't know but it's like on the show it
didn't look like it was a [ __ ] and
she was like uh I keep house just fine
and I just made you dinner so like go
[ __ ] yourself that's not what she said
but that's probably what she was
thinking so she just leaves the table
without finishing her food he's like hey
where are you going she's like yeah well
I'm done with dinner not really hungry
anymore oh she's joking yeah okay and I
was like I was like please hit him okay
so Sandra gets even more interested in
the occult after like she found that
Cornerstone thingy and one night again
she's like reading her little occult
book she just has I mean apparently she
had a bunch but she just had this one
because I guess it was like neat looking
um and she's like in bed reading and of
course Steven's whining about that oh
it's getting late why don't you put your
book away and go to sleep blah blah blah
he's always like bitching about
something and I was just gonna Sondra I
was like please give this dude something
to [ __ ] about it's like I'm just really
getting sick of his constant [ __ ]
bitching so over the next month it says
Sandra kind of forgets about the stone
thing in the front yard
so one day she's in the basement looked
like the basement uh doing laundry and
Gene is down there with her like playing
with his little toy soldiers or whatever
and she said and I guess Gene heard this
too but they said they heard like what
sounded like heavy boots like walking
across the floor upstairs because they
were in the basement like I said
so they thought that it was
um douchebag Steven like home from work
early so they were just like oh let's go
up and see what you know what fresh hell
he's brought us from home today so they
go up there but nobody's up there so
like okay that's a little weird
and then Sandra is like looking outside
thinking maybe somebody's outside and
then I don't know if she actually heard
this or not because she didn't say it
but they had it on the um reenactment
where she heard kind of like it sounded
like a weird kind of like breathing or
like a sighing kind of noise like like
something like that and she was like
what the [ __ ] was that and then Gene was
like what the [ __ ] was that you know
what I mean so it was like that kind of
situation now she said that this alarmed
her a little bit but it didn't really
scare her all that much she said she was
actually just sort of curious and she
figured that maybe
um you know by making such a big deal
about finding that Cornerstone maybe she
kind of like and inadvertently like
invited the ghost to the school Master
like inside the house and maybe now he's
like you know fooling around in there
like goes too
so after that that's apparently all that
happened like about that time because
then it said a few years go by
and Jean is now 11 so I'm presuming that
this is what like three four years later
something like that
so one day he's out in the yard and he's
kicking around a soccer ball with and
two of his little friends are over so
Steven pulls up in his truck again and
we're like oh what's gonna happen now
and the soccer ball like accidentally
like hits the passenger side rear view
mirror
and it's just kind of like bends it a
little bit and of course Steven has a
[ __ ] meltdown about that even though
it was obviously just an accident now
the real Gene at this point he said all
my friends were terrified of Stephen
when I was growing up
um you know like as soon as he came home
everybody's scattered you know what I
mean like oh bye we're out you know what
I
mean
so Steven basically says uh tells Gene
where you're gonna have to mow the lawn
every weekend until you earn enough to
like afford to replace that mirror it's
like you don't know what money is and
blah blah and like all this other kind
of [ __ ]
so Jean says the real Gene says Steven's
always yelling he's always angry it's
like it never ever said any single nice
word to him so at this point like Steven
and Sandra's relationship you know is
starting to suffer more because Steven
just again seemed very ambivalent toward
Gene like he would say so like other
reenactment I kind of laughed when he
was like your son doesn't understand
like the concept of money oh I mean our
son like he said it like real [ __ ]
condescending like that I'm like oh my
God what a [ __ ] [ __ ] I mean that's
a great actor I don't like I said I
don't know what the because he really
like made me want to like actually hit
the actor because he was like so
hateable
um yeah
so Gene and Sandra they said one of
their favorite things to do when Jean
was a kid was they both were really
really into horror movies so in the
evenings they would like turn off all
the lights and they'd pop some popcorn
and like put a scary movie on and they'd
like watch it and it was like really fun
so they are doing that one night and
then of course Steven has to come in and
ruin everything like he just sneaks up
and he's like Boo and like laughs like a
jackass and you know it just kind of
ruins everyone's good time so Sandra
says to him it's like um how about you
go have fun someplace else you know what
I mean which I was like yeah go girl
um so he's like yeah I'm gonna go watch
the game with the guys and she's like
yeah good riddance chode so but she
didn't say that but I'm sure she was
probably thinking it so then like the
day after that
Sandra and Jean are at Denise's house
she's the neighbor by the way for a like
a barbecue or something
so Gene has to run back to their house
like to get something and while he's in
there one of the dining room chairs and
Danny pointed out this is very much like
Poltergeist which it is that's probably
where they got the idea
so one of the dining room chairs starts
like shaking around like it was actually
like a pretty good special effect I
thought like it looked pretty cool like
I would [ __ ] my pants if I saw that in
real life you know I have seen that in
real life right that's what I mean so
um so it's kind of like and it's also I
don't know if this really happened or
not but it was kind of making a
like an evil laugh kind of sound like
it kind of said it reminded me of like
that you know the movie fun house the
Toby Hooper movie yeah it kind of
reminded me of like that thing that was
out in front of the house like oh like
it kind of reminded me of that so the
chick I don't know the chair is laughing
I don't know so it's like moving like
that and it kind of like shot toward him
because he was like sitting on the couch
doing something and it kind of came
sliding down the hallway and then it
stopped and he just like Frozen like
staring at it like what the [ __ ] and
then it looked like the seat of it which
was kind of like vinyl and it kind of
like smushed down like somebody sat on
it at which point the kid was like yep
I'm out and like you got up and ran the
[ __ ] out the house yeah I kind of called
[ __ ] on this on the scene at least
the way it was shown yeah so I had
something similar to happen to me I was
telling Jenny at time I was like how the
hell could he just stand there
foreign
I was walking down the hallway and red
was in front of me and he stopped and
looked into into the uh bedroom
through the doorway and froze like he
was seeing something and I kind of ran
forward to like two or three steps to
look and see what it was he was looking
at and the rocking chair was sitting
there in the corner of the room with two
stacks of towels wiped towels on on the
sitting on it and it was rocking back
and forth Memphis basically like
somebody had a somebody had it and was
rocking it back and forth hard
and I saw like a blur on the top of the
chair and that blur just kind of
vanished and just weird
and
I saw it and it took me two seconds
maybe I saw the whole thing until I
processed it everything I described I
saw that maybe two or three seconds
as soon as it
as soon as I realized what I was seeing
I ran ran past him
and turned around you looked and he ran
too yeah he ran too he's right behind me
and then he stopped and turned around
and looked back in there and it had come
to rest
so man just stand in there and watch
that and then that thing coming towards
you like that uh you'd have jumped out
of your skin you know what I mean you
have
you have survival instincts you know
yeah I kind of feel like it would be
something else if like you were in this
room and you saw it over there and it
was kind of going like that like you
might freeze up and be like what the
[ __ ] like you yeah like you weren't sure
what you were looking at yeah but if it
started coming toward you I kind of feel
like you were just instinctually like
probably just run away from it yeah I
think not just let it come right up to
you I
looked at that rocking chair [ __ ]
flying back and forth violently
and I only looked at it long enough to
actually process and understand what it
was I was seeing as soon as I realized
what I was seeing I was like nope
ran you know it was [ __ ] scary don't
like that that was one of the first that
was one of the few things I actually
caught in the act of moving everything
else was just it had arrived or
you know something moving out of the
corner of your eye but I was trying to
catch it actually moving stuff
now Lois and red saw it and throw things
you know but
I always saw things kind of like
arriving or they were already there you
know turn around and you turn around or
something there that wasn't there just a
few seconds just a second ago you know
something from another and it came from
another part of the house you're like
how'd that get up here that was from
downstairs you know
little small objects usually
Danny says the father was shitty to Gene
because he wasn't his own blood which is
shitty as [ __ ] I agree uh the mom makes
a mean looking lasagna it looks so good
it really did didn't it that was a good
looking lasagna yeah so the the case the
first thing that starts off kind of
sounds like Poltergeist
rspk recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
but as the story goes on it it's not
poltergeist-like
uh
and it didn't follow a poltergeist Arc
of getting stronger and then doing
certain things and then ebbing and flow
and then lasting a couple of weeks and
fading away that's usually how it goes
and then you know it's always unresolved
no no narrative behind it usually
there's no narrative
if there is a narrative it's a narrative
that some psychic came in and made the
narrative up you know what I mean it
didn't come from the Poltergeist itself
there is no narrative
foreign
mirror was gonna cost Stephen an arm and
a leg when in reality a wet rag would
have fixed it yeah pretty much it
basically just kind of like bent it like
that you could have just like kind of
I'm not like sure what because that was
like an old car but you probably could
have just bent it back and cleaned it it
wasn't broken or nothing yeah he just he
just wanted to whine about something he
was a big whiner yeah Tammy goes that's
right a fight or flight but yeah
yeah I admit I probably would have if I
probably would have punched the chair
I feel like keep flying I mean I'm like
you know what I mean here it comes like
it's like a plan but like I said I don't
know if that's they I'm sure they
probably exaggerate it because I will
say there's not a lot of poltergeist
type phenomena yeah going on in this one
so I kind of feel like the rare
occasions that it does happen I think
they kind of maybe amped it up a little
bit yeah that's all I'm gonna say I
think Lois Lois was a good example
of what Tammy I'm just Mr Tabby Tammy I
think my aunt Lois was a good example of
what your average person does when they
see something move and it's paranormal
I was in the living room and red and
love us were in the bedroom looking at
something because objects had been
moving all [ __ ] night and I heard
Lois scream and then laugh
and I ran in there and the I didn't know
what had happened
and she was the the bed spread was on
the [ __ ] ground
wrapped around both Lois and Red's feet
and um
red was [ __ ] looking up at the top of
the
above the uh the sliding doors of the uh
the closet there was like uh it would
flatten off where you could put stuff
above the closet all right because it
had a vaulted ceiling and it didn't go
all the way up and I could see the
corner of a pillow up there and he was
pointing at me because the pillows are
up there and I was like what and then I
heard Lois scream again and jump up and
down goes oh my God whoa whoa whoa whoa
she's like dancing and then stopped
we're like what happened she goes it
grabbed me
and it took me a few minutes of asking
them what had happened they were looking
at the bed
three or four pillows flew off the bed
one over their heads went on top of the
closet and Lois screamed
and when when she screamed the bed
spread flew off the she said it came off
the bed like a manta ray just in a
single piece and went around and wrapped
around their feet like a wind but there
wasn't a wind
and then she felt something come up out
of the floor and snake around a leg and
snake around her waist and go up her arm
and vanish she said It felt kind of like
a cross to the a cold
snake but you couldn't see it with a
hand on it she said it felt like a hand
he came up out of the floor and wrapped
around her and then jumped off
we couldn't see it I was looking right
at her
she just said she could feel it
and pretty creepy so it's screaming and
then laughing because what are you gonna
do
you know it's oh yeah it's got to be
like yes like disbelief yeah you're like
holy [ __ ] did that just happen yeah sure
yeah no I didn't see the pillows come
off
Louis red said when the pillows came off
the bed they were spinning slightly and
almost like they were in zero g
and they were moving fast red red
estimated they came off there probably
about 50 miles an hour
and then
and there was nobody there
and when the bed spread came off they
kind of heard them
a whoosh sound you know like a that like
like a wind coming but they didn't feel
anything
it's just the sound of the bed spread
and it's and Lois said it like lifted up
off the bed an inch and like there was
uh like a anti-gravity or a wind
underneath it and it just slid off it
should look like a an octopus
like a living thing
whatever had a hold of it had a hold of
all of it not an edge of it and pulled
on it you know
weird
of course I didn't see that
that was low as the Red Sox Denny says
the Unleashed is actually a scarier
episode but still on the same level as
this one yeah well maybe we'll do that
one next because
um I don't think we've done that one
actually El padrino just arrived uh
hello everyone says hello there hello
welcome to the show
so yeah so we were talking about like
the chair like flying toward the kid
right yeah and how he just was he did
run away like when the chair well not
when it came at him like it when the
chair like looked like somebody was
sitting in it like when it went down
like that didn't go down that was just
like a step to her he's like yep I'm out
so he runs away now he said that he felt
like something evil was in the house
because you know
now Sandra at this point is still
talking and she's talking to the kid
because you know he says what happened
and she's like well I just think it's
the ghost of that school master
um you know so don't like get too upset
about it so she's actually an aspiring
writer so she starts writing about like
the stuff that Gene experienced right
so after a few weeks uh at least
according to the show it says Gene sort
of forgets about the weird chair thing
which I kind of find that hard to
believe you know what I mean like a
[ __ ] chair like went like that and
like flew with me and laughed like Toby
Hooper's fun house I don't think I'd be
forgetting about that anytime soon but
you know so they're all supposed to be
going on this boat trip like a fishing
trip one day
but of course Steven gets angry because
he's always getting angry at something
uh because Gene is just sitting in the
boat like just kind of [ __ ] around
he's not breaking anything or nothing
he's just kind of sitting there going
woo like pretending to steer the boat so
Steven is just like get out of the boat
what are you doing in there and he's
like pissing at morning and he's like um
yeah I worked hard to buy this boat to
make Sondra happy I was like yeah I'm
sure she really gives [ __ ] about your
boat dude that's why that's why he like
Justified paying all that money for it
blah blah blah so finally uh Gene is
like [ __ ] that I don't even want to go
in the fish and trip anymore um and he's
like I'm just gonna stay home now Sandra
is like yeah I think I'm gonna stay home
too because obviously this is not gonna
be fun for anyone involved but uh
obviously Steven will not allow her to
stay home because she's like oh well my
friends are gonna be there and it'll
look bad if you don't go with me like
what am I gonna say to them
you know I'm like well they probably
already know your reducion so they don't
even you don't have to say anything they
probably figured it out but um yeah
Sandra's like well I don't want to leave
the kid home by himself and Steven is
like oh he's plenty old enough to leave
him by himself like he's not a baby blah
blah so they just leave him there he's
like I'll just go to my friend's house
so that's what he does Gene goes over to
his friend's house for a little while
but then he comes back home after dark
and his parents aren't home yet
so he's sitting in the house by himself
reading a little comic book or whatever
and then he starts hearing creaking like
somebody walking around and he sees a
shadow go by like outside the window now
when he goes to look like one of the
chairs like starts going ham again
because like that and then like he sees
a guy in the window like the little like
um strip of window like next to the door
so this dude I think he had a suit on
but I don't know if he really did but
the guy just he described it the real
Gene he said um the dude was tall and
thin and he said his face was red and
disfigured so he's just like out there
he's looking all like [ __ ] he didn't
really look like Freddy Krueger but his
face was like all gory like his skin was
peeled off or some [ __ ] like that
because Zach said he saw this he's like
I remember this episode that head in the
window freaked me out so bad as a kid I
didn't want to look outside at night
yeah this was actually one of the
scarier uh apparitions I guess
so he sees that and he just so screams
and screams and screams
now moments later like the doorknob
starts rattling and then Stephen and
Sandra come home while Gene is still
standing there screaming his head off
and Steven is of course like oh I guess
you were right like he is a baby and he
wasn't old enough to stay home or like
alone because he's like sitting here
screaming and I was just kind of like
it's when is the truck gonna hit this
guy when it's like sooner rather than
later please it's like oh my God
so Gene tells his mom about
all the stuff that he saw like The
Apparition and stuff and she finally
shows him the Cornerstone I was because
it's been like a few years I was under
the impression that he already knew
about that because I thought she brought
it up like at breakfast one morning and
I thought the kid was sitting right
there like back in 1965 but maybe not so
she actually goes and shows it to him
and it's like this is probably the dude
that you're seeing and then Sandra says
oh I've had a bunch of encounters with
this spirit and I've never felt
threatened by him and I'm like they
didn't show that on the show though and
they did this is the first time they
mentioned it like they didn't show her
having any encounters with this spirit
like they didn't bring it up like before
now but I don't that I don't know it's
really weird
um so Gene said he felt better like
after his mom talked to him she's like
uh she tells him she pulls like a um you
know like uh like Scatman Crothers like
talking to Danny in The Shining where
he's just like oh they're just like just
like those scary movies we watch it's
like they can't hurt you
so that night Sandra stays up after
Stephen has gone to bed to read her
occult book because she's got to sneak
into it and she wants to see if there's
a way to remove the spirit from the
house because she's like well I don't
feel threatened by a particularly but
Gene is freaked out by it so I'm gonna
see if I can get rid of it
so she's down there reading and of
course Steven comes down he's like where
are you come on like you have to you
know and she has to like hide the book
and all this other kind of stuff it's
ridiculous
um yeah don't take too long to come to
bed he says and I'm just like oh I gotta
be like please oh my God so Jean
apparently doesn't see the ghost anymore
after that
apparently but new prop well the show
says new problems have developed I was
like well actually it's the same problem
it's Stephen it was like the big problem
so this but at this point like it's now
become unbearable because this has been
like several years so Sandra and Steven
are like fighting all the time and to
escape the house Gene starts going to
church here we go in the churchy
direction uh with his friend all the
time and he really likes it so he just
like keeps going he really likes church
and he really likes being out of the
house because he doesn't want to be
around his parents so they're fighting
all the time
Sandra meanwhile uh starts to have this
recurring dream
where she's like driving in her car and
she's passing a sign that says welcome
to some place in Texas and sort of like
seeing Stephen like kind of go and buy
like in her
side windows like the car windows you
know what I mean it's not she doesn't
look like she's running him over
unfortunately but it's like he's like
kind of like in the side sort of thing
and I think there's like a flash of like
somebody in a black robe or some [ __ ]
like that so she's said she had this
dream like a bunch of times like over
several weeks and she said it felt like
really Vivid like way more Vivid than
her regular dreams
so finally
um Sandra breaks down and tells Stephen
look I can't tolerate your ass anymore
um and she divorces him and then she
ends up moving back to Texas city like
her hometown because she still had
family there now on the drive down she
has a vision like back to the dream she
was having like the dreams she was
having were like foretelling the future
because she hadn't she said she actually
hadn't left Geneva Ohio in a really long
time so it was really weird she had like
this really really weird like deja vu
when she was driving down to Texas
because this road looked exactly the
same and like the signs looked exactly
the same and like she had seen them
already you know what I mean
so Sondra's able to find this little
house for them to live in now in one of
the rooms under this rug she finds a
pentagram of course how many episodes
have there been where they move into a
house and they pull up a rug and be like
I mean that can't be that common come on
now
I'm gonna put that in a story because
that's what I'm saying because it's a
meme
oh look a hidden pentagram underneath
the carpet it must be Satan yeah
I've literally never thought of a movie
it go let's go back It's gotta be it
goes back to the Indian burial ground
story yeah
oh it must be an Indian burial ground
yeah yeah I couldn't be white folks
white folks would never do yeah white
folks would never haunt this place
which is pretty now I want to see a now
I want to see a horror movie called
white folks who never on this place
somebody make that just put it up on two
man it'll be fine
but yeah so um so she finds a pentagram
under the rug there's a lot of that
going around on this show
um and she's actually like not scared
she's like excited about she's like ooh
witches lived here because like I said
she's rolled into the occult and
everything and so she figures yeah like
there was witches and she's like oh
maybe it's meant to be like maybe
um you know I was meant to like move
here you know I mean like it's a sign or
whatever
so over the ensuing few years since I'm
assuming this is going to be we're
talking like six seven years like
they're jumping ahead so Saunders having
a hard time I mean she's a single mom
obviously
um and she said well she was married to
Stephen for a while and she didn't work
then she was you know she was a
homemaker
so she you know she just kind of had to
take whatever work came along and she
was kind of getting behind on her bills
and everything like that
and she wants to be a writer like I said
she's been trying to sell some of her
stories to a publisher but hasn't really
been able to get any interest or you
know anything in that regard
um and her and Jean have kind of started
to drift farther apart I think they were
making a bigger deal about this and it
probably was because it's like you know
she's a single mom he's like a teenage
boy it's like once you know when they're
teenage boys it's like they want to go
hang out with their friends they don't
want to like you know hang out with
their mom that'd be weird because so you
know so it's kind of like Sandra is like
oh well there's a zombie movie on
tonight and he's like you know I'm not
into that kind of stuff anymore mom like
I had stuff to do with my friends blah
blah you know what I mean and she was
like getting bummed out about it and I
understand that moms do but like I said
that's just a very normal thing that
happens I didn't think that was that
weird at all but I mean it is kind of
lame that he's like oh I don't like
scary movies anymore I was like [ __ ] you
dude scary movies are awesome so uh so
yeah
basically
um she decides that she's gonna get more
into the occult more into Wicca because
I guess she's lonely you know what I
mean and she's kind of also hoping that
it's going to change her life for the
better she said she also liked it
because it was more like uh you know men
and women being equal and she liked that
kind of thing because it was god and
goddess and all that and like I said she
liked that they believed that you could
like harness energies and like change
things and like make positive changes in
your life and [ __ ] like that
I've started calling she makes a little
face when she gets upset with this and
it looks like a little mad face so I
started calling her little mad little
mad she because she's just like
she makes a little face like that fan
ceiling fan turns on she looks at and
goes
eyes go like that
yeah it seems like it's hilarious it's
hilarious or a little mad face yeah it's
not just when you turn the fan on
whatever anything whenever you do
something that pisses her off she makes
that little face at you yeah and I was
like oh a little man she's mad at a lot
of things she does yeah it's funny when
she gets mad where'd you do like that
Billy the talking cat yeah commercial
where she you know she pushes the
buttons yeah and Billy's favorite button
is the one that says mad yeah okay cats
are angry I guess so I feel like if we
got one for Pookie she would be pushing
the bad one all the time too
that's a bad mad you know what I mean
yeah she'll totally do it because you
can just tell by her face
so uh so yeah so Sandra sets up an altar
um she said she didn't really have
anybody to like teach her how to do
Wicca or anything like that so she was
just like basically reading books and
figuring out how to do it so the first
ritual she does she said was one for
kind of like prosperity and she said it
actually seemed to work like a few weeks
after she did it a magazine actually
buys one of her stories and sends her
like a big check I don't know how much
it was
um so she was like very encouraged by
that so she's like oh I'm just gonna get
even more into it because that [ __ ]
works and I got some money that's pretty
awesome
Gene though who is about like 17 or 18
at this point like he's in height like
about to graduate high school
um he really does not like this he's
scared of the supernatural stuff and he
starts kind of like you know drifting
farther away from her Gene said that his
mom like talked about the occult like
all the time and he kind of started to
feel like well we just gone completely
different ways like we've become
different people or whatever so
um she's all like oh what are you gonna
do after graduation you get to find a
job and he's like uh Bye Mom I'm joining
the Air Force so basically like a couple
days after he graduated from high school
he went away and joined the Air Force
and he said that their relationship
during this time period was very very
strained and he just thought it would be
good to like get out and like make his
own life or whatever so because Sondra
is now in the house alone she gets like
way more into Wicca at this point so
over the years like while he's in the
military like Gene kind of like loses
touch with his mom right so he's in
there for seven years and then he goes
back home like to Texas City now when he
sees his mom this part made me laugh
when he sees his mom he's shocked
because she's all Goth out and he it
he's a little bit judgy about it gonna
say she had dyed her hair black and it's
like and she had black clothes like a
black blouse on and black pants on and
her dyed black hair I'm like oh
scandalous and he looked at this woman
and I'm going like oh yeah she'd make a
fantastic God
no I can't I mean this was many years
ago but I'm just saying I don't know she
was supposed to be but yeah I don't know
when this was supposed to be
I mean it's hard to tell because like I
said she was pretty she was much older
yeah like on the show not even old goth
women [ __ ] no
they don't look like that well I like I
said I have my theory they age Gothic
they age God Jenny's 50. okay they look
like this they look like this in their
60s and 70s
yeah
yeah look at Cassandra Peterson
yeah that's true you know
she looks to be Jenny's age
yeah and she's significantly she's 74
than me yeah yeah yeah she looks great
actually no she looks [ __ ] sexy yeah
yeah
but yeah so this yeah this part made me
laugh because he was like oh what's this
all about yeah so you know your black
clothes and your black hair and like I
said even the actors didn't really look
that weird to be honest she just looked
like she was like from New York or
something yeah
um so he's also like real shitty about
all her wicked stuff in the house even
though I'm like yo you haven't even
lived here for seven years
you go away for seven years and then you
come back to your house and your mom is
nice enough to like let you stay there
and you're just gonna come in and be
like oh you redecorated it looks like
like with all your like [ __ ] Pagan
[ __ ] or whatever I was just like oh
boy so here we go again
um yeah so he goes back into his old
room and she said oh it's the same as
you left it other than this painting
over his bed and he's just like oh well
this wasn't here before and he's like
there's a painting and it was it was of
the devil and I'm like not exactly it
was just kind of like it was like a horn
it was like the horned God and like the
goddess kind of like a wicked thing you
know what I mean it wasn't really
devilish or offensive or anything I
don't know if the real painting looked
like might have been of the devil I
don't know but it was like the one on
the show didn't look that offensive
um it wasn't very well painted but it
wasn't like scary or anything but he was
like very offended by it so he like took
it down so because in case you couldn't
figure it out uh while Gene has been in
the military he's basically become like
a super super Christian
um and you know what I mean although
I'll get into that because he actually
talks about that
outside because he's written several
books uh I discovered
and um he says like a slightly different
thing
about when he became a Christian you
know what I mean maybe I mean maybe he
just became like more of a super
Christian when he was in the military I
don't really know
um so I don't know so he's talking to
his mom and he's like hey how's it going
mom and she's like oh my God my life is
like so much more awesome now that I do
Wicca which I'm sure she probably didn't
say but whatever but Gene is like oh
whatever and like he thinks that she's
like messing with things that she
doesn't understand right like I'm sure
he understands them so much better
so uh that night he kind of like peers
at his mom she's like in her room like
doing her rituals or whatever
I know I was like weird dude what are
you doing and it's like she's peeping in
yeah although probably she should
probably like close the door or anything
and all she's doing is just kind of like
a protection spell you know what I mean
oh please protect him from yada it's
like totally harmless so he's just like
peeking in there like I said like a
creep and um just kind of like scoffs
and like shakes his head like
that that Mom of mine she doesn't like
her and her Supernatural whatever
so yeah he's going to be like almost as
big a douche as his stepdad was gonna
say
so later that same night evidently
like he's sleeping in his room and this
kind of like bright blue glow like
starts at his window now he said at
first he thought it was just like a like
headlights car headlights but then he
like it keeps going and he wakes up and
he apparently sees like a bunch of
what it looked like on the show was like
a bunch of dancing white lights like
somebody was waving a disco ball around
kind of like oh just off camera that's
what it kind of looked like to me and
they were also making a weird noise too
like a kind of
here kind of noise like that
and then he sees a figure in a black
robe that looks like his mom
it like she looks all satanic and [ __ ]
and that she points out and says destroy
him like like that and I was just like
uh okay do I think he really saw that no
so the next morning uh apparently he
leaves the house after that and like
dicks around all night somewhere and
then uh because when he comes back in
the house the next morning like
somebody's like oh my God where were you
I was like worried sick and he's like oh
worried sick where you've yelled bit
like he was the real douchey like that
and so he's like was that you in my room
last night and like tells her what
happened and she's like well obviously
that absolutely was not me why the [ __ ]
would I be in your room like in a hood
like going destroy him like what the
[ __ ] why would I do that I don't know
but um so he's like well it looked like
you I was attacked you know so like I
said I don't I don't think he really saw
this I don't really think so
Jean basically says that he's scared for
her
and he thinks that she let something bad
in and she's like I would never do
anything to hurt you or anything like
that he's just like whatever [ __ ] it I
gotta go out of here and he leaves now
he goes to the library and finds
something in an occult book about the
little dancing white lights that he saw
in the room uh that says that they're
Sprites and I was like okay yeah little
Sprites in the room yeah it's like
squirt
white squirts yeah we're about seven up
that's what I said they're not seven UPS
they're great little seven UPS
oh my God
so uh so yeah Sprites and they and these
are a product of Witchcraft evidently
because the book said so
uh Gene says that he thought that his
mom's intentions were good
but that she had inadvertently let in
something evil because basically she
didn't know what she was doing right so
he's like well you didn't want to go
back to the house but he thinks he has
to because he figures that his mom is in
trouble and like needs his help or
whatever
so he goes back home but his mom like
isn't around at first so he goes into
his room and he sees that Sandra has
hung his little gold crucifix that he
left there on his Bible in the middle of
a pentagram
that it looks like she Drew on the wall
like did she draw that on the wall it
looked like she drew it on there with
like a [ __ ] grease pencil or
something was like okay or painted it
and then she hung the cross on it I
don't know what that was supposed to do
so he got like super offended by that
and um he's like and I thought my mom
was casting spells on me and he's like
yeah I'm out of here so he leaves the
house
what's she doing hi looking at the fan
yeah no she's looking at me now that
she's looking at the fan she does not
like that fan yeah she does not like
that she's right underneath it looking
straight up at it like that fucker's
gonna fall she thinks it's gonna fall I
think I think because it rocks because
it like wobbles a little bit yeah she's
like that's gonna fall but then why are
you underneath it she's like because I
gotta like mine I'm gonna catch it she's
gonna get if it falls I'll be the first
to know
she'd run like hell of that yes she
would I guess she would come down
spinning and hit me first wow yeah right
in your little bald head yeah bald head
and [ __ ] put hair back on my head
would it spin it'll probably cut the top
of my head off it probably would yeah I
don't know though it's just wood I don't
think it would it would probably it
would hurt but I don't think it would
like not meow I don't think it cuts top
of your head off though yeah it may be
pretty it was you'd be prettier with the
top of your head cut off yeah it's all
scarred up and [ __ ]
maybe I'd be able to put my [ __ ]
snake flick and eye patch on yeah there
you go you look like a super villain I
mean even more
you are kind of starting to look like a
supervillain you do need some scarves
some scars scars like what like one real
good in life like I said you need like a
blow filled kind of yeah going down
there and like going down like that with
the eye patch yeah look like that damn
Klingon General out of their [ __ ]
there yeah [ __ ] Star Trek movie
General clang or whatever his name was
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
yeah all right so uh okay where was I
all right so he leaves the house so he
starts to believe that the ghost of the
school master that he supposedly saw
this years ago was actually an evil
spirit that his mom accidentally
conjured up so at this point he cuts all
ties with his mom thinking that she's
too far gone he just can't deal with her
[ __ ] anymore so Sondra is like really
upset by this obviously she because
she's like well I would never do
anything to hurt him now she does
continue to practice Wicca though now
one night she's doing a dedication to
Isis the goddess not the not the group
you know
and [ __ ] goes sideways so she starts
seeing the little seven Ups Too the
little Sprites or one of the little
seven ups and uh also starts hearing the
creepy voices which sound like they're
saying like a destroy destroy like that
kind of thing and I'm just like all
right black metal lyrics yeah it's kind
of that's kind of what it Cookie Monster
was
like oh my God somebody playing Venom
around here but yeah so um it kind of
sounded like that and then uh these kind
of like dark figures start like kind of
reaching out of the walls like this
black arm comes out the wall and then
like a face comes out the wall and just
all these weird kind of noises and [ __ ]
this was kind of like the biggest thing
that happened really and it was brief
you know what I mean like she starts
seeing all the Sprites going like get
off me get off me and then like all this
stuff comes out the walls and then so
Sandra freaks out and just destroys the
altar she tips it over and she breaks
all the [ __ ] and everything like her
little Isis figures and she's like
hoping that that would close the doorway
that she opened yes and I mean I guess
it worked but and she's like she thinks
these were demons now note that I'm
noting that she didn't describe exactly
what she saw though but she did give up
Wicca after this so her and Jean like
reconciled after that Gene became a
minister which we'll get into in a
minute uh who actually counsels people
who have been victims of the
supernatural
uh and Sandra gets published
although I couldn't find anything that
she well I did find some books under her
name like Sandra Waldron her name is
right and I found a bunch bunch of like
religious books that were written by Bob
and Sandra Waldron but I don't know if
that's the same person or not because I
saw like a bunch of people named that
um but she never practices Wicca again
yeah now on the outside okay so Jean his
like I said Gene is actually his middle
name and he does not have the same last
name as his mom so it took me like a
while to find him you know what I mean
like I'm not a stalker I promise but I
was just trying to do like some research
and I'm like why doesn't he have the
same last name as his mom
um but his name is actually Reverend
Daryl Jean motol m-o-t-a-l that's his
actual name so he doesn't have the same
last name as his mom like his name is
Jean but that's his middle name
now he wrote a book in 2011 and it was
called the school Master the
autobiography of a demonologist okay now
here's the synopsis from Amazon the book
is not available unfortunately so if you
want to read it then you're [ __ ] out of
luck unless you can find it at a thrift
store somewhere but the synopsis says
Platt R Spencer was a famous School
master I'm assuming that this is the
school master that they found like the
the Cornerstone in the house were yeah
who lived during the 1800s in the small
farm town of Geneva Ohio 100 years after
Platt R Spencer's death in 1864 okay so
he did die
a young like in that year a young boy
moved on to Spencer's farmland and into
a house it was haunted by an entity that
may have been the spirit of Platt or
Spencer himself this is the true story
of how that young voice survived many
frightening encounters with the entity
and how he eventually grew up to become
a demonologist and Schoolmaster himself
this is the autobiography of Reverend
Daryl Jean motol also known as the
Paranormal preacher that's what he's
known that's how I found him yeah you
know what I mean okay
so he also wrote a book this is really
weird so he also wrote a book called The
Witch's son because that one they said
like at the end of The Haunting um
episode like it was in the end credits
because you said about it you said oh
witch's son so I looked for that on
Amazon and I couldn't find it at first
but then when I found out what the
dude's real name was and then kind of
back cataloged and like look then I
found it but I don't know why it didn't
come up when I put in the title I mean
maybe it's not on Amazon no it is it is
I mean it's well okay the description
and the cover is on there but you can't
buy it like it's not available anymore
okay so I'm assuming that they either
like self-published it right or I mean
it was a long time ago like I think they
published that one in 2007. yeah so yeah
so the one that he wrote called The
Witch's son
um that one was like I said acknowledged
in the credits of a haunting and the
Amazon synopsis of that one says uh
based on the true story of a young boy
haunted by evil entities uh dark Spirits
terrorize him for many years until he
becomes a you're gonna love this until
becomes a man
and leaves home to take an assignment
with the U.S Air Force at guess where
area 51. area 51. so he's gonna uh do
UFOs and goes he's covering all the
bases maybe he was assigned over there
I'm thinking maybe maybe but the thing
is is I think that's Lockheed Martin I
think that's all contractors I don't
maybe there's Air Force down there I
mean I don't know it sounded a little
bit too they might be running security
perfect although you would think they'd
probably use private security too I'd
have to go see yeah it just sounded well
like when I read that I actually kind of
like laughed out loud I'm not saying
that he didn't work at area 51. I'm just
saying that was like I was like oh of
course well there's a lot of jobs up
there I know I'm just saying that I just
thought that was like funny it's just uh
because it's like Paranormal I was like
oh yeah quite a coincidence that's what
that's what I said it's yeah it's not
impossible it's possible but I'd have to
look more into it but it's possible and
then he said then the this is from the
Amazon synopsis soon after he takes this
assignment I'm assuming at area 51. yeah
his mother asks him to join the family
religion which I'm assuming is Wicca
yeah he refuses then his life
mysteriously begins to fall apart as his
mother seeks to destroy him with all the
fury of a woman scorned
so he wrote that about his mom and she
still like agreed to be on the show with
his ass might well it might be
sensationalism well obviously yeah it
might be but I was like wow that's kind
of a shitty thing to say it doesn't take
long before his marriage and career are
destroyed and he finds himself back home
with his mother
through many battles both natural and
Supernatural the man overcomes the
forces of hell that come against him and
he becomes the Reverend Daryl motol aka
the Paranormal preacher a demonologist
dedicated to helping victims of
Witchcraft and the Paranormal yeah he's
a there's millions of them I know I hate
when that happens but that's uh yeah so
so that the haunting episode is based on
that book apparently because they have
it like at the end of the credits and I
was just kind of I just thought that was
really interesting that
so they kind of softened the show a
little bit at least from the point of
view of that thing where he's basically
like oh my mom tried to like get me to
be a wicked and then when I wouldn't do
it like she yeah low-key cursed me I
mean that sounds like what they're
applying yeah like I said it might be it
might just be sensationalism I'm trying
to get you to buy his book
because that's that's a that sounds like
a good good tale it does yeah I mean I
don't know like it might be it might be
a good story I wouldn't pay for it or
anything but it's like if I find it in a
library it might like skim through it
it's a niche market
uh it is uh I will let you sell at a
religious bookstore yeah bookstore yeah
um I also found an article about him in
the Star Beacon
from right around the time the episode
aired for like for right around 2007.
and so basically I'm kind of like um it
actually says where the house was in
Geneva Township in Ohio yeah um it
doesn't give the exact address but it
says it was on North Myers Road so
anybody in that area of Ohio maybe you
know where it is
um and he's talking about his mother was
dabbling in witchcraft in the occult and
uh there was something else now see he
says and this is an interview with him
he says I became a Christian when I was
eight years old
which that's not exactly what they said
in the show but okay uh my experiences
went from mild hauntings in Geneva and
progressed as faucets would turn on by
themselves they didn't show that in the
show by the time I was 12 years old the
experiences became more profound
Furniture would move across the room by
itself which okay they kind of showed
that so more profound at 12. that's
Poltergeist
yeah I saw a male Apparition which yeah
they showed that in the show motol's dog
Nikki they didn't have a dog in the show
uh saw The Ghost and attacked it and he
said the ghost threw the dog across the
room so they didn't show that in the
show either maybe they didn't have a dog
available
um then he does say like yeah his mom
got involved in witchcraft he says I
think my mother was losing her mind
she went from a sweet mother to a
paranoid angry person and I didn't know
her anymore so then it says about him
joining the Air Force and like being in
like Area 51 or whatever and uh taught
him talking about spirits becoming
dangerous and he founded this thing
called The Soul and Spirit Ministry so
it says where he helps people
disentangle themselves from witchcraft
Cults and dangerous religious situations
and also he's a demonologist so he'll go
around if you have demons like you can
call him up I don't know if he's still
alive but um he was only in his 40s when
this show came out 45 I think he was
um you still alive probably yeah I don't
know about the mom but uh but yeah
so yeah so that's basically like
I think that was all that it said that
it was because then it said Motel
releases second book the Paranormal
preacher the truth about aliens and Area
51
. so it's about aliens yeah yeah so I
told that's I forgot about that so that
was the third book because he's written
three
so I was like oh my God I gotta see if
that's available did he ever write that
uh it's it's on Amazon but it's not you
can't like order it like it's just says
this title is unavailable but it has
like all the stuff about it like when it
was published in the cover and all that
any reviews
um I think that there were I don't think
there were any reviews of this I think
one of the other books had like two
reviews and I think one of them was four
star one was five maybe he did pass away
maybe that's why it's not available
I kind of feel like probably what
usually happens in those situations is
because usually they're self-published
um and they either self-publish them
like in the old school way where you
publish them and you buy a bunch of
copies yourself yeah and then like once
you run out like you can't you sell them
out or it could be that he did pod like
what I do like print on demand and the
company that he was using maybe went out
of business yeah maybe it could have
been that because I had that happen in
one of my books that's why I republished
it like the I because I had it published
by like a small press and they went
under so they didn't have the print one
available anymore so I had to do like
another print version of mine because
the rights have reverted to me at that
point so it could be that I mean it's
been a while since these books came out
the area 51 one came out at the end of
2007. okay the Paranormal preacher the
truth about aliens in area 51. so like I
said that's why I think that's why I
kind of laughed when I said oh of course
he works like at Area 51 because it's
like he had to cover all the bases you
know what I mean you want like you want
the Christian audience you want the
ghost people audience the demon audience
and also the alien onions so you know
not everybody it looks suspicious and
have to see the material myself you know
I don't want to judge it just on the way
but just looking at it on the surface
and how this is intertwined with church
there's going to be a bunch of damn
ulterior motives probably this had been
had this whiff of Billy Bean about it
yeah it was a billy beanie type of
episode
yeah like warranty warranty Billy beanie
kind of situation yeah and you know we
weren't there I don't know this material
real well didn't read the books I don't
know what his claims are it's just just
that situation alone I'm already a
little bit skeptical I'm skeptical
you know yeah amazing uh the story
Parts elements of this story just seem
like classic Poltergeist but it's not
he's in that one description says he got
it it got stronger when he got to be
about 12. so they said that sounds like
something would happen to poetry yeah
that was like from the one of the book
descriptions yeah turning turning
faucets off and on which wasn't in the
in the in in the episode it was in the
books which that that leads more towards
something that Poltergeist or rspca
would do
and then if you start claiming that it's
a demon or thinking that it's a demon
they do demon-like things because it's
just fulfilling what it is your
expectations really you've suggested to
to it how to act it's really just your
subconscious
subconscious [ __ ]
with psychokinesis you know
yeah subconscious mind is [ __ ]
powerful and I don't know why nobody's
really going to be able to explain it
Sir Stuart hammeroff's trying to with
all that Quantum Soul stuff and uh
Quantum Consciousness
um that
reality and time space and matter aren't
as real as you think they are they're
all kind of relative
and there's certain parts of you that
are
do certain parts of your Consciousness
that's happening slightly out of phase
with space-time it's in another
dimension and over there
reality isn't as real so if you have an
altered state of consciousness sometimes
you can alter matter which that's Mind
Over Matter
which that's [ __ ] that's quite a
claim you know what I mean but there
seems to be some evidence in quantum
theory for this
you know hyper Dimensions Dimensions
outside our physical dimensions that's
what they're you know that's what
they're talking about
look into uh Stuart amarose Stuart
hammeroff and uh sir Roger uh Penrose uh
they got some new stuff on YouTube
Quantum consciousness
and they get into this kind of stuff
indirectly indirectly they'll they'll
say you know hey coach this is not
computation it's not happening inside
the brain there's some kind of a Quantum
field that's happening uh which might
you know and then
a hammeroff will say which might explain
some of the stories we hear that fall
into realm of paranormal we're not
saying that that's that that's real but
it might support that you know that's
that's as far as they go
get up although I remember his old
interviews he's like no that paranormal
stuff if it exists it's this and he goes
I think it does exist
because he had people putting them under
anesthesia knowing things that they
couldn't have known and having out of
body experiences
you know
that's what that's how he got into it
he's an anesthesiologist
which that's a mysterious thing
how does anesthesia stop consciousness
I've seen it happen
Jenny was coming out of surgery I talked
to her for a whole half hour and she
wasn't in there seemed like she was
there but she wasn't there she didn't
remember any of it
because the drugs shut your
Consciousness off even yeah he's just a
robot during that time she seemed
totally normal though
which is crazy to me
I mean well the same thing the first
thing I remember I don't know how long I
had been awake the first thing I
remember was just
um getting in a car no I remember waking
up in the chair like in the in the
recovery room yeah I remember waking up
in the chair and I remember seeing you
and I said you know and and I said oh
like I was kind of in a little bit of
pain but
and then I was and I think the first
thing I said was like how long have I
been up or how long have I been sitting
in here yeah and you've been there for
about a half hour yeah and you said that
I've been awake and talking in a half
hour and I didn't remember that yeah
but the weird thing about that is that
it doesn't even take innocent because
that was really the first time I'd ever
gone under anesthesia because I'd never
had any kind of surgery or anything like
that before so it was like kind of a
weird experience like I don't I remember
nothing like I was on the table and they
were like here count backwards from and
I was like 99. you know what I mean and
I didn't remember [ __ ] until like I woke
up in this like absolutely nothing I
know some people like do wake up and
that's got to be horrifying but I didn't
remember anything
so um but I was gonna say that like
sometimes
when I was younger I don't think I've
done this in a while but when I was
younger sometimes I would fall like I'd
be at my grandma's house and we'd be
like you know watching Johnny Carson or
some [ __ ] like that like at like late at
night and I would fall asleep on the
couch and my grandmother would wake me
up to you know kind of be like hey go on
into bed or whatever like don't sleep on
the couch all night and I she said I
would say all kinds of [ __ ]
and like she would tell me the next
morning like oh you said this and that
the other thing and I did not remember
any of that yeah and that wasn't even
anesthesia that was just like me being
half asleep yeah and I seriously did not
remember anything like all I remembered
was like oh I was watching David
Letterman and then all of a sudden I
woke up the next morning and she told me
I said all kind of [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
and I was like huh that's really
interesting has to do with each one of
your brain cells your little neurons has
it has a bunch of little microtubules
coming off of it they're extremely
microscopic they're real small
and there's a bunch of photons flowing
going through there
and um little light particles
and it's acting kind of like that
microtubule seems to be acting kind of
like a meta material
and it seems to be acting like a quantum
computer
well those little photons and all those
subatomic particles inside those
microtubules
they're in superposition with each other
and there's has to do with certain
things like called collapse of waveform
which is uh some of the smallest
the smallest amounts of measurable time
possible
they're trying to figure out how fast
time moves and what is right now because
right now it's constantly moving how
thick is the present
think about that yeah how thick is the
president it must be infinitesimally
small because it's constantly moving
yeah it's not really a quantity you can
like grasp because it's constantly
because all this [ __ ] is moving and it's
and it's traveling through time and the
present is infinitesimally small and
it's all moving in different
different speeds and different
directions relative to each other things
are kind of in slightly in different
times
some things are in the future and some
things are in the past
although you're experiencing them as the
present but it's it's an illusion so
there's a bunch of weird [ __ ] and
there's stuff happening inside your
brain
this quantum
Quantum Consciousness is you know
basically what they're talking about
it's it's happening outside your
they're talking about a soul basically
what they're talking about and it's
giving you the feeling of being it's
called koalia an experience
and computers and robots can't do that
no binary
based digital computer will ever have
the feeling of being
it's going to have to be a quantum
computer
which is analog it's not digital
and then there's going to be a bunch of
problems but Hammer off
postulates that uh AI will only be a
simulation it will not be a living thing
that it can't be
it's not biological and it's not analog
I read a book about that topic like a
few years ago and they pretty much came
to the same conclusion but I mean never
say never but they had a pretty
convincing argument they said it will
convince you to convince you that it's
real it's not it's an illusion of a
living being it might be extremely
intelligent
but it and it might be
um uh it might have the ability to adapt
and change and solve all these problems
but that thing does not feel like it
exists it's not there it's just like a
person under the effects of anesthesia
they'll be able to do all this stuff but
they're not there the way Jenny was
seeing now I'm like I'm really kind of
curious about if somebody was like doing
kind of a study where because you know
sometimes they do this like weird sleep
studies or like about your nightmares or
like they hook up [ __ ] to your brain and
like do weird [ __ ] to you like to to
kind of um make you have like out of
body experiences and stuff because they
can do that with that God helmet thing
that they call it Michael Persinger I
think is the guy that does that
um I always kind of wanted to do that I
thought that would be like fascinating
like to be in a study like that
because I'm just always kind of
interested in like all kind of weird
[ __ ] that your brain does because it's
probably doing all kind of [ __ ] up there
without me knowing about it well when
they were describing how thin the
present is and because things are
moving all around you some of them are
photons at the speed of light not
everything is actually in the same time
you just it just appears to be from
because it has to do with relative to
certain points of view
you know like something over here and
something over there seeing photons
moving at the speed of light they're not
experiencing in quite the same way uh so
some things are kind of in the if you
were to freeze time
just freeze it
some objects would be slightly in the
past and some objects would be in the
present and some objects would be
slightly in the future
that's weird when you think about it
we're talking about the trillionth of a
second in the future yeah like
noticeable not noticeable but it is the
thing is is that
you can still measure it so that's a big
deal how could that thing be slightly in
the future by the trillionth of a second
and you can see it
you know like a ball flying at you but a
lot of its particles are slightly in the
future that's a weird concept
so like what exactly did I say when I
was when I was no just normal
conversation just a normal conversation
I didn't say anything like not like
weird or anything nope seemed totally
normal you're just like you're because
it's normal brain function
you're talking about the surgery and
getting out of there and [ __ ] how you
felt and [ __ ] you know and yeah I'll
be out here in a minute you know just
normal
huh
but there wasn't any Quantum processes
going on so you didn't have a feeling
could you tell nope had no idea you
couldn't tell couldn't tell
couldn't tell you were a robot though
but I couldn't tell you seemed normal
it was just crazy because I until later
when I told you it's like yeah
and she said no I don't remember he says
you were talking we were talking the
whole time
yeah I don't remember that like I
remember waking up like I said in the
recovery room and I was still in the
chair yeah but we left a few minutes
after that like I remember you kind of
like taking me out to the car I remember
that
as soon as soon as you were awake and
you know like I knew you were awake and
you said I don't remember that he said
yeah yeah come on and they said okay she
can go that's because they know how long
it takes yeah so just put you in the car
yeah I mean I remember that and you were
fine if I ride back you didn't you
didn't seem to care
I remember right I remember being in the
car yeah
I remember everything like I said I was
I remember being in the recovery room I
remember that but I remember only being
in the recovery room for like a couple
of minutes no you were in there for
about a half hour
we were talking and then we got up and
left yeah you were talking
yeah huh and it's just uh
see that's fast I had no idea that you
were unconscious right but you know
there was fascinating it wasn't
there uh you know the anesthesia gets in
there and see
pep uh hammeroff was saying that they
know that anesthesia Works they're not
quite sure how it works they just know
that it does yeah and they it has to do
with it swap it stops all those little
photons from flowing down the
microtubules inside each one of those
brain cells so each each brain cells can
kind of compute trillions of operations
because those things are tiny in there
so it's not just one act and one neuron
it's one neuron and trillions of other
little things in there that can house
photons
you know so each little cell is a super
computer
well he says that it's going in there
and it's stop it's it's interfering with
the properties of the the The Meta
properties like a meta material those
little tubules so the photons aren't
flowing down properly
so your sense of being your sense of
existing
um Fades away
you're unconscious even though you're
walking talking
you're a robot yeah I was like I was
like an AI you're AI right and that's
that's the way an AI computer would be
it wouldn't have a sense of feeling or
qualia
a sense of existing wouldn't have a
point of view right you know it wouldn't
experience things the way you do it
takes another process
they'll eventually figured out but I
don't think they'll be able to make a
synthetic version
like I said Never Say Never but well it
does seem kind of like a like a hard
some people have argued that that that
an AI creature doesn't need that that's
not what they're for
they're just a fool you into thinking
that they're what they're alive and to
do yeah it depends on what you wanted
yeah I guess yeah it's more like an
assistant super computer type thing and
it could keep you company but you don't
really want you don't it doesn't need to
have a feeling of of being real right
that might actually
work against it
because it could live for a long time
and you might have to ask it to destroy
itself
so yeah that might be opening up a whole
ethical Quagmire that you don't really
want to get right you're like you're
kind of an old model and we're going to
replace you with the new model we're
going to shut you down
and you go oh no don't shut me down it's
killing me you know yeah because if
they're self-aware right then it might
as well just be a human right might as
well be a human so it's probably better
not to have the AI to have a sense of
being just to sit just to
um
to a certain extent give you the
illusion that that it has that it has a
sense of being right
like a weird conversation that we went
into yeah yeah
are you hungry
yeah kind of all right I'll make this
we've been on for hour and 40 minutes
like I said it was like twice as long as
the actual episode that's okay though
this was uh like I said this wasn't
this was a little bit of an unusual
episode like as far as the haunting goes
but we got some fun uh we got some fun
[ __ ] out of it especially after I found
out that the guy like wrote a book about
how he worked at Area 51 so I thought
that was kind of fascinating and I
always it always makes me laugh like the
whole pentagram under the rug thing and
to blame the Goths thing and that always
kind of like makes me laugh and that
stepdad was like such a douche that it
was like fun to like make fun of him so
you know it's talking about relativity
it's not the same kind of Relativity I
was talking about go go see Roger pavros
and Stuart hammeroff I mean they got
Nobel Prize
you know [ __ ] pambrose is like the
[ __ ] top physicist so go argue with
him about what the way the [ __ ] Works
they don't really don't know how quantum
theory works because it's [ __ ] weird
all right it's very weird
but they were just saying that uh
it's very difficult to Define what the
present is
you know because it's the present
doesn't last long enough
you know if you were to stop time just
see the present how much time is the
present how thick is it
you know
some things are on either it's extremely
thin and some of the things that are
happening are on one side of the present
or the other
and they were trying it's very vague and
motion has a lot to do with it
but it's for people smarter than us all
right so I don't I'm not gonna pretend
to pretend to be able to solve some [ __ ]
like that I could imagine what they were
talking about
but I you know
you have to have probably like 160 IQ to
even have a chance figuring that out I
don't have that my IQ isn't that high
and most of those dudes are lying in
physics anyway they're just making [ __ ]
up a lot of them according to other
physicists
there's no way to test it so they're
just doing mental gymnastics and writing
papers for Academia and pontificating
and smelling each other's farts you know
but there's no way to prove a lot of
that [ __ ]
because it's happening in Dimensions
that they don't even know that they
can't prove exist
all right so probably tomorrow are we
gonna do Reservoir Dogs tomorrow
maybe maybe we haven't decided
would you rather well I gotta finish
Graham Hancock and I gotta cook so I
know that but we'll well we got to do a
movie let's go for tomorrow though yeah
I don't think Reservoir Dogs is very
it's very uh long no I don't think it is
either we can watch that and then you
can watch the grand Hancock after that
those shows are short
do you know what I mean yeah all right
so uh we'll be back tomorrow probably
talking about Reservoir Dogs
so thank you everybody for dropping by
today and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow afternoon good night